I'm not sure if this one is Pleasant
okay okay what does the Bible say about
divorce and
remarriage are adul
adul well adultery and
death the of the spouse okay the only
ground for remarrying someone else can
you marry
someone
who
someone if someone who has been divorced
mhm yeah okay let me
pray Father in
Heaven there's usually a simple answer
what sounds like a complex question tell
me what to tell your people in Jesus
name I pray
amen the Bible has one clear reason for
divorce one clear reason
adultery the church may give you several
more
are you with me yeah the Bible has one
clear reason for the divorce that's
adultery you cannot divorce a woman
because she can't cook or because you
know whatever adultery that's why when
you consider marriage think twice once
you in it you're stuck are you with me
but stuck is not a good word you in for
life so think twice you can't jump in
and jump out because she broke a
fingernail you can't do that now
adultery is a reason for divorce course
now the Bible El makes it very clear the
innocent party can
remarry the guilty party must remain
single for
life of course it doesn't happen because
we do what we want the innocent party
can Remar but God prefers
reconciliation Malachi 2:6 the Lord of
Israel saith that he hateth putting away
Calvary shows that God prefers
reconciliation to divorce are you with
me but adultery is the clear biblical
reason for
divorce the innocent party can remarry
the guilty party must remain
single so yes you can marry a divorced
person if you determine that the person
has been divorced and the person is
innocent because someone decides to
divorce you there's very little you can
do are you following me doesn't mean
that you a monster because you got
divorced it may not have been your fault
at at all so an innocent person can
remarry or can be married by someone but
the clear biblical reason for divorce is
adultery but the church allows others
presumably based on the
Bible all right but remember when the
flood came they were marrying and giving
in marriage are you following me don't
make the desire for marriage a god
there's some women let me pick on the
women that's all they think about and
they run into trouble they married the
first man with a pulse are you following
me and they run into
trouble mhm go
on in Exodus 28 God gives us
instructions about how we should keep
the Sabbath day holy but a lot of seven
day Adventists don't believe that it
applies to strangers or individuals that
are within their Gates MH they allow
them to watch TV stay in their homes
when they go to church and do whatever
they want to
do will the individuals be that allow
them to do this on the Sabbath be
charged by God will it be considered a
sin on their part even though they're
not the ones doing it let's recite the
fourth
Commandment remember the Sabbath day to
keep it holy six days shal thou labor
and do all thy work but the seventh day
is the Sabbath of the Lord thy God in it
Thou shalt not do any work pause pause
that includes doctors and nurses that's
right but let me add something before
you call the police let me add
something El white writes a medical
missionary page 26 paragraph 2 it may be
necessary for doctor or nurse to go in
in that case go because it's proper to
ease suffering on the Sabbath but only
do what is required to relieve suffering
and whatever money you paid give it to
the
church so don't go on Sabbath saying I'm
a nurse but knowing you want time and a
half Every Act is judged by the
motive Thou shalt not do any work thou
nor thy son thy daughter thy man servant
nor thy made servant nor thy cattle nor
thy stranger is within thy Gates
if it's your
home you are responsible what happens in
that home you cannot say he's my
cousin because God made Adam who put him
out are you following me you can't say
he's my cousin let him do what he wants
no no no no as long as he's in your home
he is to follow the rules now you cannot
convert him but you can let him know in
this house there's no TV on Sabbath
there's no smoking there's no dominoes
for you West Indians there's no
there's no such thing on the Sabbath day
if you don't like it where you can spend
that day elsewhere and then come back at
Sunset are you with me we must put God
first the honor of God above the comfort
of man if it's your home you must be
responsible atmosphere in that home on
Sabbath or any other day of the week for
that matter so yes god holds you resp
responsible for allowing in your house
what should not happen on the Sabbath
day
mhm strictness is not
harshness God said don't touch the
ark other trying to help he touched the
ark and we know what happened to him but
God has said don't touch
it and God does not
joke next question